oh my god holy qurían facemasks my
girlfriend loves these and honestly they
just look terrifying on her I know
nothing about Korean skincare I've seen
it like some k-pop stars and they look
very smooth
apparently this stuff is like miraculous
snail spit is a thing I'm ready to look
flawless
alright butterfly eyes perfect for my
problem area this will brightened me up
I'm ready to be brightened get at first
first a nice with slimy in there just
keeping these up hide away like a little
ghost oh I feel like a Looby superhero
yeah this just feels like there's a used
condom on my face not that I would know
what that feels like I can feel my skin
it's like drinking water
I'm hoping this makes my skin tighter
just like not the best looking thing but
it feels great
yes I'm gonna be a tiger you know I
don't get pampered enough so this is
perfect this is horrifying this is
horrifying the [ __ ] is this a fruit
roll-up beauty here I come oh you're so
good oh it's so cold wait let me see
myself okay I gotta take this off my
roommate will wear these and she'll come
out of the room and she'll be like hi
how's it going and I'll be like oh my
god remember that movie the mask of Jim
Carrey
that was based off the horrifying true
story of this mask if this were just my
dating profile just me out in the woods
sort of like I'm wearing the skin of
somebody I murdered I actually want to
look like this all the time now I
understand what furries are all about
milky piggy bubble mask already a big
fan of the milky baby don't know how to
feel about that man call captain crunchy
and [ __ ]
oh it's itchy okay Stephen who's a milky
piggy me me me they're moving oh my god
pop rock into my face oh god it's all
puffy
it's all puffing up this is so grotesque
oh my god it you look like Squidward
it's burning a little more than the
other ones like tiger balm on my face
like they could stop Vegas off there are
tiny little elves just blowing on my
face it's just like quit you know I had
a great time with this that's fun my
skin does feel less oily no it feels
really good Steven probably pooped his
pants and couldn't handle it but that's
okay
I'm gonna go buy some of these and enjoy
my girlfriend I don't want to see that
in the mirror ever again out behind a
corner you see me jump out like I'm here
to hide be a happy sight for anyone